dans une forêt du nord de l'Ukraine ces
militaires s'entraînent au
déminage certains sont des nouvelles
recrues d'autres reviennent tout juste
du front à l'Est pay pour le moment nous
avons quitté la zone des combats ici
nous reconstituons nos unités nous
intégrons de nouveaux combattants il y a
aussi de nombreux blessés qui reviennent
dans le rang après sêtre remis de leur
bless serent a été
blessé j'ai été blessé à la jambe par un
éclat d'obu dieu merci tout va bien et
parfois je suis même plus motivé encore
à finir le
boulot dans ces immeubles abandonnés ces
hommes s'entraînent à l'assaut et à la
défense dans des conditions proche du
réel ils savent que très bientôt la
moindre erreur pourra leur coûter la
santé ou la
vie
on a un petit problème de
communication et munition aussi dans la
vra vie je nai jamais fait t ass je d'ut
ch mais c'est pour ça qu'on nous
entraîne on doitêtre prêt à
tout des commandants d'unité éud latique
militaire au
programme la capture d'un village selon
[Musique]
les
le commandant du bataillon se sert d'une
carte en accès libre pour montrer la
zone où d'autres unités de la brigade se
battent encore nous suivons la situation
sur le terrain où nos unités se sont
déplacées quelle position elles ont
repris à
l'occupant en réalité la ligne de front
dans cette partie du donbasvouu peu
depuis des mois contrairement au listes
des combattants mise à jour au gré des
morts des blessés et des nouvelles
recrues